a DC grocery store Giant Hello grocery
store the southeast DC has removed name
brands it's got generic brands but no
more name brands Advil Colgate tied it's
gone it's gone because people keep
stealing and the shop owner he says I
don't want to do this I'd like to sell
the name brand products but the reality
is the tide is not a profitable item in
this store because it keeps getting
stolen in many instances people stock
the product and within two hours it's
gone so it's not on the Shelf anyway you
see he's seen theft rise tenfold in the
last five years this is literally why we
can't have nice things we sell out all
of the Social Capital so that we can
have cheap consumer goods and the irony
of it is we end up without even the nice
consumer goods because people are
stealing them so much that they can't
even put them on the shelves